so what am I here to talk about today
I'm Libby I'm here to talk about you
know why do we use these Cuban eighties
being why is it so popular why is
everyone you know so interested about
deploying containers are using
containers or you know machine learning
or web applications so but before we
dive into that let's let's have a look a
little bit of a background right what
what do we do and when when do we need
we deploy applications well back in the
day is right we used to have large
applications right and and we used to
build this large application but you
know in the recent past what what
happened is we we basically decided that
it was a much better idea to just you
know break this large application to
smaller components and each component
would have like you know a single focus
we will have an API a front-end and each
of those would be independent right and
and we thought it was it a good idea
because we could have quicker
deployments right everything would be
separate said and we could could be
released independently we said you know
each team could work on a single feature
so that's a good idea and we it's also
overall less risky right because if a
component goes down is just that
component
it doesn't take down the entire system
and you know it's developers we said
this is a great idea we should keep
doing it as much as we can however there
is something else going on right so
there is you know some of us were
perhaps more into the infrastructure
side of things are saying these kind of
things and and thinking well it is great
but when I have a single when I have a
single application that I could just
bring that single application and put it
inside a box and that would just run
okay but we did now we don't have a
single entity anymore we have you know
these individual individual components
so we we should drop each individual
component it's in its own box right what
we call virtual machines for example but
you're RT is that as developers we like
you know we don't just break things in
for we tend to be you know little bit
more you know we take things to the
extreme sometimes and and we end up with
a lot of applications so a lot of
application actually they introduced
quite a lot of challenges on the
infrastructure side of things and if we
look at it some of the challenges the
first challenge that we can we can think
about is you know when we had this
picture when we
these computers right with computing
units then those tend to be like quite
large computers that could run a lot of
things right and if you look at the
ratio things that we're using the
operating system and in a space which
was usable for you for running the
application there was a tiny bit using
the operating system was using a tiny
bit at the rest you can use yourself now
if you had only a few applications then
you know you would have this split and
overall the the memory and CPU used by
your operating system be a tiny bit
right so if you think about it two to
three percent to run the operating
system it's okay right it's very small
but when we switch to something like you
know smaller components and a lot of
them what happens is we tend to run
smaller application and smaller which
machines and the ratio between what is
used by the operating system and what's
used by your application like your your
web application changes quite a lot
right so we're seeing some some shifts
from two to three percent to more than
double to say from six to ten percent
and if you think about it if you have a
bill on GCP for example of a thousand
dollars then you're spending a hundred
dollars in running operating system so
some money that you'll never see back
right it just lost the other challenges
usually when we build this application
we we used to put this application
inside these boxes and everything will
be fine right we will have Noddy box and
another box and if the application was
smaller than there would be just a
little bit of gap right which wasn't
easily we couldn't use lines and it was
still okay but now with this application
that we're building showing much more
very much much much focused right
compared to what we had before we have
you know all different shapes and sizes
so if we deploy them in in these boxes
then there is a lot of white space right
which we didn't have before and now we
do which is kind of a problem and the
last sort of issue that we get that we
inherit from this sort of development
that we know we do is that yes all these
micro services we like to pick languages
there
we okay but it turns out that we really
really like them so if you if you go and
look at these you know micro-service
architecture or you know if you go in a
company you will find that someone is
watching go someone is writing in no js'
there is you know I'm gonna say some
legacy in Ruby but I don't want to
offend anyone okay but in general
morning general is we have a lot of
applications right different languages
but even if you are in one of these
companies really rigid saying we do just
Java okay really serious they still have
the same problem right because they have
different runtimes it's never just
matches the same so even even if they
pretend to be better they are not okay
so what can you do
that's one solution okay but let's let's
take it stay back right so we talked
about so all of these some of these
problems were originated by by ourselves
right so we picked these boxes we called
envision machines and we play stuff
inside but what if we change the story
right what if instead of starting with
virtual machine we started with
something else so it turns out that in
the mean time and the way some some
features in the Linux kernel that you
know they were quite interesting one of
these was country groups which is
basically when you launch an application
you can define how much memory and how
much CPU that process is going to use
okay and then you can limit things like
memory and CPU and then the other things
you can do is you can you can launch a
process like your web application your
you know your binary and you can also
set isolation so what the process can
see can you see alt other processes can
you see network packets from other
processes as well so we just you know
designing boundaries around our
application what kind of things you can
see and how much memory can use it turns
out that this sort of stuff is quite
interesting and someone said what if I
combine three things you know these
control groups namespaces and a little
bit of magic
okay and they they came up with this
right what we call Dockers what we call
containers so just a way to launch a
process which has got some extra memory
and some extra namespaces just to set
isolation and end groups so generally we
don't say this but let's say for the
sake of the point we are trying to make
but docker containers look like lighter
virtual machines like lighter boxes that
we've seen before
so if before we had days right so we had
the server and several bridge machines
that are boxes inside now we basically
if we'd run containers then we don't
have these boxes anymore and then we can
run the infrastructure much more packed
right so everything is neatly tied you
know neatly organized together which is
good and the other benefit of this
containers is that because these are
just processes where we set limits
right it's not slow as a virtual machine
I mean you must have run VirtualBox and
waited you know gone for a copy and and
come back and still there booting and
there is no hardware emulation this is
just launching a process in the same way
you launch your IDE right so that's the
same thing at the docker container is
the same same thing and then the best
part is that when you launch a virtual
machine is going to pre allocate some
memory right and CPU when you launch a
process is just going to use the memory
dynamically so this docker containers
are basically just double-clicking on
your IDE and then the first part part
part which is also quite interesting is
that this docker containers at the end
of the day what they are are just
archived like zip archive and and what
they contain is not just the code that
you run but all the dependencies and
dependencies if you're running if you're
running for example a JVM
is going to be the runtime if you're
running nodejs is going to be nano GS
binary if you're running ruby is gonna
be the MRI MRI if you're running go well
you don't need any of that it is just a
binary so we combined your runtime or
your files all together with any other
dependency of your god and we just wrap
them up in a zipped file and we call
that zipped file container okay so
that's the magic of containers and and
how they work but a powerful thing is
that if you think about it in the past
right if you had to deploy at anything
like a Ruby on Rails application or
nodejs do you need to go to someone else
and say hey can I have a box can you go
inside install a couple of binaries bla
bla bla and if it was just one that was
fine but when you had like several
application it becomes really really
complex right this this server needs to
have no js' and ruby and so on so forth
but we took a containers we don't need
any of that because we'd wrap everything
inside a container we don't we don't
care what they look like from from the
outside because they are just containers
and we can just deploy them whereas
containers
so containers are great I hope you share
share the same saying feeling but the
thing is if we have a lot of virtual
machines and we switch the containers we
still have a lot of containers okay we
haven't solved the problem on how do we
use these containers so it's Christmas
time okay so have the couple of wishes
you know I'm gonna have a wishlist way
with some things I want to solve this
problem of containers so the first wish
I had what if it could be something that
could manage all of these containers and
it could be it could be something that
ideally I don't need to drink to go
there and manage servers it's just gonna
take everything is it just gonna take
care of everything for me so it's gonna
basically look at all of the things I've
got and just make a single bundle okay
so only I don't need to worry about
where this application that I built are
gonna end up and then ideally I want to
also make sure that this is something
that I I can program because I'm a
developer and I like to write code okay
and you might have used some of these
tools in the past so it turns out that
this technology that managed several
containers and they've got these
properties are called container
orchestrators and the market has got a
bunch of them okay so you might have
heard of this ones but another another
example is if you're using it up your
ass is called AWS ECS which is the
container Orchestrator and it's not a
fair fight okay so cuba i this is de
facto the container Orchestrator okay so
this is fairly old graph but the
trajectory is you can see the trajectory
of cuba natives and so what why this
cuban act is why is so popular well one
of the reason why it is so popular is
because you don't need to think about
your service writing you don't need to
think about this computer that you have
to deploy your applications what cuban
Ivies does is you install it on on one
of those the other nodes inside your
infrastructure will join the master node
and and what happens is the cluster is
just going to absorb memory and CPU or
all the Nerds okay and he's going to
become like a massive computer just
single one which is much easier for us
we only deal with one z single computer
the other interesting thing is about
Cuba nineties is that it's quite clever
but clever is not the right word it is
it's quite quite nice Tetris player so
if you think that you know this boxes do
we create it they come all different
shapes and sizes right cumulative what
it does it usually pay to play Tetris
with your infrastructure you know as
more containers come in unit we'll just
find the best lot to place your
containers right until the end you get
something like this which is great if
you like Tetris and it's also great if
you like you know efficiency because as
you can see here we're trying to
maximize the space that we can get out
of our servers and then the last one
again I'm developer by trade so I like
to program things and change things and
so everything you're doing Cuban eight
is just an API call ok so you've
probably seen you know this is a cool
quote request and I can query the API
and I can query you know the application
that I deployed and then the resource
documentation so I can you know I can
just read the documentation and create
more endpoints so if I want to create if
I want to create an application I can
just say curl create an application you
know curl create another node curl
provision load balancer so everything in
humanities is just an API call and
that's why it's so cool so do you
believe me
I just made up everything it's demo time
okay
so before we do the demo though just
just a quick description of what we're
trying to do so ideally this is what we
want to build right we want to build the
red pages that people visit okay that's
what we do all day however sometimes
these red pages they become super
popular right so we need two copies
instead of one so what do we do to
distribute the traffic between the two
I hear lot Bansi from the crowd very
well now we might have more than one
application because awfully you know
where we work they don't have like a
single product or a single micro service
they probably have more than one like
like this what if I want to route the
traffic to both micro services how do I
distribute the traffic I hate a load
balancer from the crowd not really but
that's the thing okay so so we actually
we have two layers of two to level two
layers of load balancer easing and when
we want to distribute the traffic
between several services on an inner
infrastructure so we have an external
load balancer and an internal load
balancer and then the applications so
Cuba Navy's we do exactly the same thing
we just like to call everything with
different names okay so instead of
calling look say the internal load
balancer internal load balancer we call
them services because you know in
computer science that's a very specific
term the service and then instead of
calling the external load balancer the
load balancer we call it the ingress
okay this is really bit more specific
thankfully and and why couldn't the
application or container containers
where you can call them pods so that's
how we call them okay so that's that's
basically how we deploy application in
Kuban ages so let's have a look
so we got we discussed about three three
different things we discuss about the
ingress the service and then our pods so
the way it works is ooh first of all we
create a container yes correct me
so containing what it is we usually
create container from a list of
instructions so the list of instruction
is usually called a document and this
contains basically it's like a glorified
eyes or in VirtualBox right you say I
want to start with a boom - I want to
start a couple of things and he stole my
application that's the same thing we're
doing containers in this particular case
I built a hello world up in Ingo and
just packaged inside a container then I
can build a container with docker build
- g4 the name I can gonna call it a load
and then hopefully will not let me down
okay so this is gonna take ages and we
can move on so what we do when we have
this container then we just define how
we want to deploy it now
everything we do in Cuban 8 is we
actually drive this very nice yamo file
okay so just to configure it a
description of what we want the end
product to look like and what the end
product will look like is a single
application okay what's the name hello
world
oops and what's the name of a container
okay it's called demo I build the wrong
one but you get the idea we're basically
just describing what what that should
look like then we have the service which
is the antenna load balancer and the
ingress if you think it's a lot of
llaman yes it is a lot of llamo and
Cuban of these engineers are usually
called also yeah mall engineers because
that's what we do all day okay
so once we once we have those then I
have a cluster running locally oh by the
way this is just created a container
it's it's local so wonderful when we
have this these resources locally then
what we do is and we have a cluster
right our cuban edges cluster in this
particular case i'm running a local
they're called mini cube which is
running on my machine because I was
afraid that the internet would not work
and and usually what we do is we send
these Yama files to the cluster the
cluster would read it and then create
the resources on our behalf
now to send these instructions we use a
command to command line to record cube
city L which everyone pronounced with a
different name keep cattle queue control
I say cube city L and then we say
and we just send resources you can see
that when we went to create these
resources then the creative resources
are we submit the request but it doesn't
it doesn't wait right it's just going to
return immediately but in the background
what happens is queue areas will go and
create these resources for us I can see
hello ward here and then the ingress
okay so I can see that created all of
the resources can I see my application
of who's gonna work yes I can
okay so that's the application so you
can see ckf GED
what is that
ckf Judy
okay well good
now the good thing is about Cuban
eighties is that we generally have a
single application but that's you know
we like things to scale so generally
what we do is we scale the number of
replicas and we scale the number of
instances of our application and the way
to do that is by writing what we call a
deployment which is what I just showed
you generally the reason why we use
deployments is because in Q&A is when
you create the deployment then the
deployment looks after your pods right
Lucas after your application and in if
one of those application was to go down
then Cubans will bring it up ok so let's
have a look at this one quickly so what
I can do
I can go in my deployment and I can
change the number of replicas which is
the instances of my up from one to five
and I can see there are five new
applications running now so what if I go
and delete this one
who then I do a get pause but are still
five running again okay this is because
as one is deleted communities will
replace it with a new one okay so it's
doing a lot of stuff for free for us
okay but one of the things that we do
very very frequently when we deploy
application is with deployed application
and then we have a better version okay
with the void version one and then you
know a couple of days later we just find
a way to refactor everything right and
redeploy it again now Kuban it is is
quite interesting on this face because
it automatically does what we called a
rolling update right it's going to do an
upgrade of your of your application with
zero downtime so how do you do that well
if you look at if you look at this at
this particular deployment we have three
application with a read page so when you
say I want to upgrade from version one
to version two this is what happens
Cubans will create a new version of the
application okay and we'll replace it
with the old one create a new one
replace it create a new one
replace it okay because it's doing it
one at a time then the traffic never
goes down right we definitely we never
had downtime so let's have a look at
that as well
so what would I should show you before
we start is that the application exposes
a version okay this is version one so
what we can do
[Music]
hopefully this is going to work nope
Oh
um I'm pretending this is normal but
it's actually not so very mind would be
I got version 1 you can see version 1
running okay so what I do next I'm gonna
go and change DS from version one to
version two what would you expect to see
now is this is going to continue to be
one all the time
what's your guess is you're gonna go to
- yes hopefully I can have a free-throw
X so the way we check that is we do a
cube CTL apply - ah
okay and it switch back to the sleep and
we see what happens
well
mortu
one in two two two
okay eventually is going to switch the
two right you can see now the whole
traffic is going into version two
so we just need a rolling update but
just changing the version of the
application in the specification and and
that's basically and curators did a
rolling update for us what is my mind
okay so so that's basically why everyone
is so excited about containers and
kubernetes it's quite easy to create
deployments it is quite easy to do
rolling updates and and because
everything's is encapsulated is very hot
it's very easy to scale to several
servers as Grau so who is using this and
why so I think a good example of who is
using Cuban eighties for the sort of
large-scale processing is this company
called open AI so what I do is back I
think two years ago now they used to
train machine learning models on on Cuba
natives and the head like these what we
call now medium sized at the time was
really large size and we've tried
twenty-five hundred nodes okay and then
what kind of things they did they
install basically something designed to
scale the system right so when the
application needs to train more models
then we'll just create more instances of
this model and we'll just you know
process more more jobs and then that was
combined with another thing in in G K
which is the cluster autoscaler so when
you run out of space like in this case
it will just create more nodes and then
keep doing this training of models so
they it turns out that they are building
a model to play dota which is quite cool
and I don't know if you heard the news
but I think this year in July they also
managed to compete with repro players as
well they run for this for competing
with pro players later they run much
larger cluster we are talking about more
than 5,000 nodes of the cluster so it's
very cutting edge stuff but at a time
the reason why I mentioned in this is
because at the time they basically
shared what kind of configuration they
had for wrong for their own cluster and
and this is what's the configuration for
the 2500 nodes so you can see that they
used 256 P P 10 P hundred which I think
RTP use and you know a bunch of the very
CPUs this is everything in Google Cloud
everything on GK can you guess how much
money is this per hour
No well it turns out there it's not a
lot I mean he's a lot I mean objectively
it is a lot so we're talking about US
dollars here so it's probably sixteen
hundred close to two thousand dollars
but if you think about it you're right
if you're a student more fear of
students probably to experience it but
if you are if you're a small research
center right you have access to so much
power
right which normally would be just for
you know large corporation or large
companies now you can go in gke click on
two buttons provision 500 note 5,000
node cluster pay pay two thousand
dollars you know for an hour and just
take it down this is unprecedented
we never had you know such ability to
create things so quickly and destroy
them even if you're sitting in your room
you don't know back home just just
mining bitcoins or you know training
models so I think this is pretty
exciting it's pretty exciting for me so
that's everything I wanted to show you
today I hope it was 20 minutes ago
more or less so we talked about
micro-services how things have changed
and in the since since from from where
we started right from these monoliths we
talked about these containers as light
of en so just processes that have got
memory and CPU limits and and we talked
about Cuban eighties as one of these
container orchestrators okay so that's
everything I wanted to show you today
yeah I think we usually run workshops on
this kind of stuff we have one coming up
the 27 on November but reality is that
we're going to do a repeat of of the
zero to Cuban 80s course which we have
done in September and we're going to do
in December what we're going to do in
this session is we're gonna do the same
three hours you're going to through go
through building an application in Cuba
next and deploying in okay so last time
was quite popular I'm not sure about
this time but
yeah I think if you're interested these
sort of space it's on the 7th of
December I think it's on a Saturday so
join me and hope you enjoy I think you
might have very much for listening to me
[Applause]